Speaker 1: C PAC finally started,
and it's really humiliating and
embarrassing. Here is the start of it with
Matt SCHLAPP, who runs the event. Remember,
much of the controversy around CPAC this
year is that Matt SCHLAPP, who is anti-gay
and married to a woman he is accused of
having I can't I can't even do it. He's
accused of having pummeled the junk of another
man sexual assault we're talking about. Many
people didn't want to go to CPAC. Here is Matt
SCHLAPP. Addressing Jim Jordan is maybe the most
powerful man in Washington. There's a.
Speaker 4: Lot of chatter in the media
about who's here and.
Speaker 5: Not here. I'm really proud
to be standing alongside someone I think might
just be the most powerful man in Washington, DC.
Speaker 1: You know, I don't think that Jim
Jordan is at this point the most powerful man
in Washington, DC, but it's the perfect person
for SCHLAPP to point to because Jordan has quite
a history of looking the other way when bad things
are being done. Let's just leave it at that.
Kurt Schlichter was there and he had quite an
interesting anecdote. These are the sorts of
colorful stories we've come to expect at CPAC.
Speaker 4: Click here and my friend from Town
Hall, who has a very important historic
distinction, he was kicked off and banned
from the Don Lemon show. I forgive. What did you
say again? Well, so I'm on I'm on the show. And
he he said, so this is when we run up to Trump.
And he says, you know, Kirk, this is terrible.
This is the worst thing ever to, you know, what
what Donald Trump said. And I'm like, I don't
know. He says he said that Hillary got schlonged
when she was running against Barack Obama. And
it's worth saying now was a good one. And I got
I said, I don't care. Hillary Clinton. I mean,
you care about that. Hillary Clinton literally
stood by her husband, use an intern as a humidor.
Speaker 1: Whoa. And he's totally normal.
Speaker 4: You can't see that. So I said
she sat there and literally stood by as her
husband used an eternity humidor and booed off
of CNN. Best thing ever happened to me. So that's.
Speaker 1: All right. A true tale of redemption
and forgiveness or something like that.
They're still doing the election was stolen
stuff. Here is Stephen Bannon interviewing
Kimberly GUILFOYLE. And someone else looks
like Miss Miss Indiana maybe, or something. I
can't tell. And playing up the entire Biden's
not the legitimate president stuff.
Speaker 4: You said the Bidens were
the occupiers of 1600 Pennsylvania Avenue. Are
you implying they did not win the 2020 election?
Speaker 6: Ma'am, I'm straight out saying
that they did not. Yes, we were an occupier.
Unidentified: It's like it's like the
equivalent of a squatter. Right. Do you
agree with that? Should you think.
Speaker 4: Joe Biden, Joe Biden,
the legitimate president?
Speaker 1: I say no, definitely
not. All right. And then a woman traveled all
the way to CPAC, I guess, because she loves Steve
Bannon. And Steve Bannon suggests not watching
Fox News anymore, which is interesting name.
Speaker 6: And what brings you here today?
I'm Bobby Rooney. And I actually came here
because I love Donald Trump and I love
Steve Bannon also. And real make a voice.
And I'm I'm with a little group in Pueblo,
Colorado, who are grandparents for America.
Speaker 1: And when you say
gun parents or grandparents.
Speaker 6: Planting trees under which we
will never sit because we're trying to
get policies out, our young people don't know
any of the policies. So they go and they vote.
Personality. We can't win
the personality war, right?
Speaker 1: It's the left that's
voting for personality. That that. Oh,
my goodness. That is genius, huh?
Speaker 6: We can win the policy
war for all in our favor. So we did
a brochure that puts Republican.
Speaker 1: I'm curious, are there any policies
that the country is moving in their favor?
I can't think of a single one.
Speaker 6: Policies on one side,
Democrat policies on the other. If you pick all
the Democrat policies, vote that way. We just want
you not to be stupid. Right?
Speaker 1: Right.
Speaker 6: You know what
you're voting for. Hold on.
Speaker 4: Ma'am. If you don't want to be stupid,
stop watching Fox for Tucker and. Geoffrey Warner.
Speaker 1: There were some, except for is there
Did you hear that? He's like, except for that.
He said, except for Maria BARTIROMO and someone
else. So this is another unhinged year of CPAC.
We will be live later today and then tomorrow
with the Trump speech. And it is it is a gong
show. It really is. But hopefully I don't have
to suffer through it alone. And some of you will
join me. Make sure you subscribe to on the YouTube
channel YouTube.com slash The David Pakman Show.